I think I'm I'm back down I think I'm
back and it wasn't about this move which
was kind of shocking but um I had some
other problem I got messages right right
after the recording started other the
the broadcast solid my um my my hard
drive it was full actually and the
stream could not it was telling me bah
bah blah blah blah please get some some
space back on the drive but the thing is
i was thinking okay it's not not a big
deal because the local recording is just
something that either don't need because
it makes a backup anyway on twitter um
so but at the end it had the message
again that even the stream is going down
if I don't get some new disk space and I
just deleting you did some stuff so what
about this now
so if I know know what what I deleted so
they can delete us actually the many
video recordings my my you tube video
files when they upload I have backups
anyway and I don't need the local copies
so um let's see him if I go to h4 is
probably going group f 33 t 7g three
this kind of stuff
come on takes rook takes Queen g3 root
cap seven now then i have c six actually
okay i'm going to take whatever if I'm
losing this I don't mind I mean you just
played a good game though so here Queen
g6 was my idea of course just taking
this ok and here it's a mate threat ok
I'm overlooking things left and right
here ah really a bad event a bad event
it's not made though it's not not quite
made but close and I okay if I go here I
has to look at g7 anyway so at least
this game it seems i'm going to win
superdry ending
okay look f5 found by my lungs on so are
you really meeting me if I take him I
can also start with this move
threatening d aid made in three did I
did I miss her maid again I wouldn't be
very surprised if I did okay maybe just
gained some space ya hear I probably
have to go up yeah offers me a drawing i
probably have to take it i probably have
to take it i cannot go down and this is
some yeah i have to take the drawing ok
this is the entire book c4 should win
unless I'm blundering
ok let's try look them I am getting a
pawn take this ok whoopty five I have
Bishop c4 now that's tough to believe
and I can I can actually take on g3 so
okay let's get the king / queen a4
played by monkey chin okay yeah e 7 is a
is a tough for a tough decision if that
is good or not not quite sure them hmm
queena firewood i can go is seven eagles
rupee aid and i can move the Queen which
looks dangerous for black quite
dangerous but I'm still not one hundred
percent sure if it wins okay let's do it
how should black window i'm not quite
sure what you're saying i'm not say i
don't see how i lose there's always the
maid on g7 so i think he he has to give
checks checks as well okay took with the
pawn igniting ideas it's actually rather
surprising
I had still some chances to draw this
okay um I don't want to trade Queens in
this position as this King is so bad how
to do that Quincy three maybe I need to
keep that punk quite clearly
I did I run into a maid Queenie one made
I'm overlooking the simple things today
yeah okay yeah good game good game I
mean I absolutely blundered that f5
phone
ok
yeah i think i'm looking at mean I
didn't play well but I think one one
thing to take from this this year's that
25 boards is maybe a bit too much it's a
I had this I mean I was a bit skeptical
when I opted to 25 games but it really
seems to be tricky because it you have
to play very very very quickly and yeah
and also think that I think the
opposition was pretty strong it was a
stronger it was a stronger field
compared to what I face on the on the
ICC for example i'm pretty sure about
that okay okay rook t5 is made on g2
this is something i should definitely
not overlooked but it can happen
especially today i can promote down I
still don't see what what next thread is
here I don't see it at all
okay I finally have to get the King
going ok I still cannot go look you five
but if I i mean i can promote
but take each xe5 has Knight f3 I don't
see a win down unfortunately
I know probably many moves wouldn't have
it really wasn't sure ok so I'm coming
up yeah here Luke f3 I wasn't I wasn't
still seeing a winner after Queen g2 I
mean it looks bad but how is black
winning now let's see ok here d success
winning right
you
he's entering here with the rook yeah I
can go back back here and attack his
pawns yeah it's again that's a pretty
draws position
so when I g2 we are thinking rook t5 now
should end the game at least that was
what that was what I was thinking ok so
what is he doing here trying to run with
the King know what is he doing I take he
is ok to probably coming yeah let's in
fact still interesting
hmm it's not so easy when ever I
whatever I take here he's got Luke a
true coming
look f8 maybe are not quite sure and I
don't want to spend too much on a single
game
yeah it's actually true women a too it's
a pretty pretty big threat
nowhere to go with a king there mm-hmm
ok anyway it was a lost last position
anyway so here I also misplayed this
position I think it should have been a
fairly fairly simple endgame win but it
wasn't at the end ok maybe f5 yep so
I'll be a piece up in this game yeah I
know I thought b7 should be the end of
it he has no check and I'm threatening
b8 made
okay so still a couple of games going on
yeah and I'm not scoring or wins they're
tough very tough field yeah in a couple
of really silly losses the kind of stuff
you see in how not to play chess kind of
books go into h5
I don't even understand the move what is
the point of this move help look h3s
idea what d7d 7 oh my god
I don't see it come on I just don't see
it ok so this is continuing but not for
long fortunately oh i blundered h4 but
it still it still is quite George yeah I
wasn't made so what about this yeah okay
okay rook takes each form just going to
take him why are you going back mr. mr.
Eko
ok this one hmm
look be three huh okay okay no and let's
see em ice i hope i can draw this game
here now is going up
yeah that that crazy game was Luca 3 was
a wind home he did resign it seems I
didn't see a move for him actually I
think I think I was winning there
it's surprised by this
he's just shooting for promotion ah
shoot I am overlooking everything today
oh my god ah how easy was so easy to
draw this by now it was so easy probably
and I found a good way to just just
screw it up as I totally forgot about
that move ah how car stupid oh my god
I said I simply didn't see it I simply
don't see anything poopit a very stupid
loss they're amazingly stupid then end
game already was pretty okay for me
yeah I know 25 games are too much but
I'm just not playing well on a good day
I can still do 25 games but this is not
a good day it's pretty much the worse
that can get now i blundered very simple
stuff maids and then pawns and fire in
very good positions so I still feel
Knight takes d5 okay
yeah this is of course also lost but i
was still continuing a little bit at the
end i cannot prevent the check down okay
I think I can resign this safely now
they're here blundered appears in one
that was amazing from a winning position
from a very even in position so
unfortunately this is a win
this business will be a draw yeah and
now this is also super easy to do okay
mmm the only thing here is i shouldn't
blunder again that's uh yeah he's a bit
too quick them King c4 g5 takes FY I'm
comfortably within the square hello and
resigning in two clicks is good I
something I shouldn't resign without I
mean you know I should only resign I'm
absolutely sure yeah I do this and he's
got see to this is the thing so I can
resign that one as well yeah that was a
really good game of like but I thought I
thought I actually had to draw already
and I mean it should have been a draw
the the way the rook was active again
that I had
I can offer draw here it's really just a
draw that's the last game no that's just
one more game that King upon ending and
where do I see the standings to as
you're standing somewhere don't think I
do ok king d 5
yeah congrats again to igniting ideas
that was a very good game yeah B takes
c3 i think i think i should should have
a draw something somewhere them King you
five Kings 26 k f6 King d5 glad your
window pawns at the tournament name oh
don't tell me i miscounted stuff here
one two three anyway I'm too tired now
it's recheck so he actually gets the
Queen I don't believe it so do i get to
trade queen somehow a green endgame I
don't really want to play that
okay it's 18 minutes against 15
took the wrong phone forcibly I don't
know I didn't really care anymore of
course then we've actually a Queen first
of course yeah you're totally right
there are you completely right that's
what I should have done
yeah tomorrow I'm going to do the
tournament's some blitz and bullet
tournaments on leeches
yeah I should have won the king upon any
where every didn't pay any attention
anymore that was a bit bit silly
allowing this kind of thing to happen
yeah so let's see there's always the
possibilities for perpetually of course
I'm just hoping for the best
yeah Eric 88 played a good game
certainly maybe you had some chances in
that end game my king was I mean your
king was active in the middle a blood
might have been some chances can really
tell I mean you just have to dash out
moosian that with that symptom of your
time control
now as I'm winning this after all it
might be winning anyway the h-bond is
very far away from blacks king
yes I'm going to win that one so that
wasn't there wasn't a great result but
let's see okay Samuel complete going to
back to that cereal so we had 16 wins
three draws and 6 losses so let's have a
quick look there what happened there was
one let's look at the let's look at the
final positions and talk about the games
briefly about the losses in particular I
want to have a look there so I lost that
game against collect your bones that was
an amazing game I mean complete mess and
I couldn't really figure out what's
going on there it was probably
completely am completely inappropriate
for a symbol very strong play also a
black very very sharp play so then I
lost against igniting ideas who played a
very good game he played especially the
opening perfectly I was kind of kind of
funny actually played exactly like my
book suggests against the Samish so I'm
that I was kind of funny I maybe had
some the stream cut oh no it says it
says I'm still own maybe it was just an
advertisement or something so I I lost
that game against igniting ideas as I
said he played a very good opening and
middle game I'm not sure about the end
game it was maybe chance for me to draw
but all in all very good game it's
crystal with an area it's kind of
unusual so I lost that one I lost
against Selfish Gene who also played
very well I think long castles there was
kind of a that was
pretty pretty awful decision so yeah and
I lost against Renaud to echo here I had
a bad position then I had a winning
position that i blundered apiece so it
was just a big blunder and against it's
like style I had a very nice position
and then blundered to two pawns there it
was really bad and I don't know I don't
know what it was then but then I ran
into a check media kind of silly you
still see the the major at the end yeah
and we had a couple of drawers I have
landed here against was orlando i
blundered the rook only one from very
nice position so it wasn't it was a bad
thing i had a red some good position
that i blundered to a loss as always
kind of sad so it was almost three hours
stream i hope you enjoyed it there were
a little bit of a some technical
glitches them i have to see what that I
get more more space on my hard drive
yeah so that it doesn't fail due to that
okay I hope you all enjoyed it I'll be
back tomorrow for the late night slot um
it's tense 10 p.m. central european time
or four in the afternoon us east coast
time i'll be back there and play some
some online tournaments on details
thanks for watching bye bye guys